foreign
[Music]
well hey you guys welcome back to tomes
of Terror my little book review series
that I do on here
So today we're talking about a New
Hampshire based author named John it's
either durgeen or Durgin I don't know
I'm assuming it's durgen but um you know
I'm not sure so I apologize if I got it
wrong now this guy apparently a very
very new face on the horror scene
I guess he co-founded uh livid Comics uh
two years ago back in 2020 and his first
published thing was like a Christmas
horror comic series which was called
Yule which is spelled Blake j-o-l uh at
around that same time now according to
his biography he was a big fan of
Stephen King and kind of his big
ambition was to be a horror writer
horror novelist so he actually did end
up fulfilling this dream in the summer
of 2022 when he self-published his debut
novel which is called the cursed Among
Us uh and I actually stumbled across it
while I was browsing through Kindle
unlimited like I said it's my Kindle
unlimited roulette
now the story of the curse Among Us
is uh pretty clearly influenced by
Stephen King's it I mean he even makes a
reference to like a character reading it
at some point in there uh got also
caught a little bit of maybe Robert
mccammon's boy's life
um maybe and maybe like a dash of
stranger things actually there are two
alternate covers
um and one of the covers that I saw
later on you can tell that it's very
much influenced by stranger things like
they're trying to get like it has the
same font and like it's has kind of like
an 80s retro throwback so there's that
kind of thing too
um but I mean just in the sense that it
centers around a group of teenagers who
are forced to contend with this like you
know Supernatural thing like this
Supernatural monster thing like being
Unleashed in their like very small town
now also there's an element of
conspiracy to it I guess too because as
The Story Goes On you discover that all
the adults in town like their parents or
teachers stuff like that you know the
cops they have uh many terrible secrets
of their own and might know more about
the unfolding events you know vis-a-vis
the supernatural thing then they had
previously LED their children to believe
so gonna say this was a fairly solid uh
debut novel it had a handful of
sympathetic characters and a really like
action-packed narrative that hardly led
up for a second I mean seriously I had
actually um planned to do another book
this week but I I switched this one and
that one because this one was like a
little bit shorter than the other one
because I you know it was kind of under
a time crunch so I wanted something a
little bit shorter and I actually ended
up reading this one it only took me like
maybe two or three hours like to read
the whole thing because it just like
kept going it was relentless but I will
say that I did have some major issues in
regards to the pacing a little bit um
mostly like the writing style uh
particularly the dialogue uh I'll get
more into that like in a little bit so
at the beginning of the novel there's
kind of like a prologue and it's 1980
and there's a guy named Henry black and
he's I mean the story jumps right in
he's like dragging a woman out into the
middle of the wood kids to bury her in a
place where no one will ever find her
now while she's still she's still alive
but I guess Henry is like knocked her
unconscious and like tied her all up so
that she can't escape so he's dug a hole
he tosses her in there and she seems to
like wake up momentarily but then Henry
like hits her with the shovel or
something like that and then presumably
proceeds to like bury her alive
so from the general Vibe of this brief
opening we are led to believe that Henry
black is a serial killer who has
murdered numerous people before this uh
that the woman that he buried was his
wife and that he believed that his wife
had been the one telling him to commit
his prior atrocities so that's kind of
like how it's introduced you know what I
mean and it's not quite that but it's
like you know that's how they introduce
the story so we then jump ahead into the
bulk of the narrative which is set in
1999. so uh it's set in a town of 6 000
people called Newport New Hampshire I'm
not sure if that's a real town or not uh
where nothing much exciting ever happens
it's just kind of like one of those
nights there's no nightclubs or anything
like that it's just kind of like oh it's
the 90s the kids go out bowling or they
you know get pizzas or rep movies on
Friday nights it's that kind of place
um now people still talk about these
murders the Henry black murders that
happened 20 years ago of course
especially because they were even
featured on Unsolved Mysteries at one
point which is kind of like a plot thing
that comes up like several times now
technically I will say the case was
solved because the killer was ostensibly
Henry black and he was found guilty and
he was put in jail and he died in jail
but there were kind of like some odd
details about the crime that nobody
could quite figure out like there were
some occult connotations or like some of
the crime scenes and the fact that the
killer appeared to have ripped the
victim's Hearts right out their chest
like with his bare hands which seems a
little bit of an implausible thing for
like a human killer to be doing so since
then
um all the adults in town had this
really hard and fast role that none of
the kids in Newport should ever set foot
in like these thick Woods that's around
the town where most of the killers
victims were dumped and it's like they
tell them it's like look that's it's a
bad place it's dangerous you'll get lost
and it's like there's kind of like a
spooky kind of thing about it because
that's where the murders took place
there's a very small police force in
town I think they say at one point that
it's only five guys and they actually
even have like stiff penalties like
fines like if they catch you in there
but of course teenagers gonna teen uh
and our four main protagonists who are
ninth graders but they're about 14 years
old uh and their names are Howie Corey
Ryan and Todd they're actually in the
woods one afternoon shooting footage for
their latest low budget slasher movie
they're all like really big horror nerds
they didn't actually mean to wander into
the Forbidden area of the forest but
they were kind of like rushing to finish
a couple of scenes before it got dark
like before they lost the light and they
kind of like lost track of where they
were at so while they were looking for
the best place to shoot uh the boys
actually stumble across this weird
clearing deep in the woods that looks
like nobody's been there for a really
long time and they find something that
kind of looks like a grave site like
with all these weird black Stones like
obsidian looking stones with weird
symbols on them like sort of peppering
the top of this mound that they find now
one of the boys Todd who's kind of like
the practical joker of the group I guess
he's sort of [ __ ] around with this
purported gravesite but then like some
spooky [ __ ] starts to happen which I
won't really spoil and they think they
see someone watching them from the trees
so they kind of get spooked and they
hightail it the [ __ ] out of the woods
now the next day Todd doesn't show up at
school
and Corey tells the other boys that he
actually had captured the whole incident
in the woods on video because he had
forgotten to push the stop button like
in the in his haste to escape like he
kind of dropped it so it actually kind
of films stuff from the ground
so he's like you guys have to see like
what's on this video so he shows it to
them and uh what's on there like freaks
them right the hell out because it was
like some [ __ ] that you know because
there was so much chaos going on and
they didn't really see what was going on
and some of the stuff that you know they
didn't see in reality like Turned Up on
video
um it kind of looks like some weird like
electrical charge like went into Todd's
Body like when he was sort of like
touching the stones around the grave
site and then his face like went all
weird and blank and they said it also
looked kind of like the trees behind
them were kind of like moving or there
was maybe something back there like
while they were all running away so
because Howie had read all about the
so-called Blackheart killer murders like
from 1980 he remembered the detail that
those previous crimes also had something
to do with these weird like glassy black
rocks with symbols on them so he goes to
the library because 1999 y'all uh to
check it out
now during the course of this
investigation he finds this old
newspaper clipping about the crimes and
it's there's a picture there of like one
of the crime scenes and it shows his
favorite teacher at the school uh whose
name is Mr B and he teaches the film
class and he's very clearly like in the
crowd like surrounding the body now this
wouldn't be weird except that Mr B
supposedly didn't move to Newport until
like very very recently so what the [ __ ]
is he doing in this 20 year old picture
so as the boys go to Mr B and ask him
about what's going on it starts to come
out that maybe something really [ __ ]
up might be going on in this town and
their fears are largely confirmed one by
what Mr B ends up telling them and also
when their friend Todd like he doesn't
show up at school for several days and
then he starts acting really really
weird so as you know and then at like as
things develop uh it becomes ever more
obvious that the whole serial killer
case like from 1980 is far more
complicated than Outsiders had been led
to believe let's put it like that and
that several of the adults in town were
privy to what amounts to like a
supernatural conspiracy again that's you
know I'm trying not to spoil anything
because this book is like really new so
you know what I mean but that's about
what all that's about as far as I'll go
with that now as I mentioned uh this is
actually like a pretty decent story it's
you know not all that original but you
know what is uh but it's still like very
enjoyable overall uh the main characters
are largely relatable especially Howie
um his perspective we're usually
following his perspective
um we jump around to some of the other
ones but we're mostly like you know
following his POV
um you know because he's and he's kind
of sympathetic because he's again like a
horror nerd he has a real shitty home
life with an abusive dad his mom doesn't
really play into it she's there but she
doesn't really play into it all that
much
um the other boys aren't quite as well
sketched out we do get to spend a little
bit of time with Ryan who is sort of
like um an overweight kid who has like
really loving like laid-back indulgent
parents but is relentlessly bullied at
school and is kind of seen as like needy
and try hard and like clingy by his
friends so there's kind of like some
conflict there
um Todd is like less delineated
um you know you don't get to know him
all that well like before bad [ __ ]
starts to happen
um I mean essentially he's like insecure
kid who cracks jokes like to get
attention and Corey I kind of feel like
was the least fleshed out like he's
barely distinguished at all uh Mr B is
actually a good character we get a few
scenes from his point of view as well
which we're actually like pretty welcome
I you know I liked him as a character
now as I mentioned also uh this book is
like a fast read has like one action
sequence coming fast on the next one and
while this did keep the story moving
along like at a really good clip it also
at times felt a little bit too rushed
and a little bit like under explained in
places and the ending felt ever so
slightly abrupt I mean there was
something like a bit of a big like epic
battle like with the big bad like the
villain but it still seemed like it
needed more like it needed more stuff
filled in it was you know what I mean if
that makes any sense I mean I also would
have liked to have had more details
about the whole like conspiracy angle
like that the adults in town were in on
like maybe some scenes more scenes like
set back in 1980 would have helped
because really the only one you get from
1980 is the one with Henry black like
dragging the woman and burying her
um or maybe like if barring that like
maybe some more scenes of like the boys
figuring out like more information like
interviewing more people or something
like that about what happened back then
I think that would have really filled in
and fleshed out kind of the history and
the lore uh in a more satisfying way of
like this Supernatural thing the
supernatural force that is Unleashed but
on honestly I think the book's biggest
flaw for me was this sort of like I
guess like rudimentary writing style I
mean red is like kind of like a tad
simplistic almost like it was geared
toward younger readers which it's not
because there's like a lot of swearing
and Gore and stuff like that so it's not
a y a but it kind of like reads a little
bit like that
um a particular note and I noticed that
like some other reviewers noticed this
as well because I noticed this just like
a few pages in the guy the author
doesn't use a lot of contractions like
when maybe contractions would be would
make the pros like flow more naturally
it made everything read is like really
stilted like there were contractions
used like at relevant points but a lot
of the time like both in the dialogue
and in like the narrative bits all the
words were like spelled out you know
what I mean I am sorry I did not do this
we are doing this and that I will do
this and that and it's like it just
seemed very weird it was it almost kind
of it came across a little little bit
like I don't mean to be mean but it came
across a little bit like it was a school
writing assignment that had to be a
certain number of words and like they
were trying to like Pat it out like you
know what I mean by using like two words
instead of just the one contraction when
the contraction would have sounded a lot
more natural
and I think it was especially jarring
too in the dialogue bits because a lot
of the dialogue was coming from like
teenage boys like 14 year old boys in
the 1990s and a teenage boy is not gonna
say I am so sorry that we are doing this
like they don't talk like that like and
not if English is their first language
so it really did sound like very very
stilted and strange and I'm just like
questioning the decision of not using
contractions all that often it was just
like a really weird decision and you
know because you know what a stickler I
am for grammar I'm one of those people
there were like a bunch of granical
Errors uh there were like some run-on
sentences which always drives me up the
wall and that seems to be something I
encounter like a lot uh in books
nowadays
um and sentences where like necessary
commas were left out uh which also kind
of drives me crazy also and this is
another thing this I see this a lot too
um there was like a bunch of misplaced
homophones if you know what I'm saying
like um like at one point he used the
word Gage
g-a-g-e instead of the way that you're
supposed to spell it which was g-a-u-g-e
um there were two instances where Vice
v-i-c-e was used when he meant Vice like
a vice that gripped something which is
v-i-s-e
um there were also two instances where
he used discrete
d-i-s-c-r-e-t instead of discrete like
on the download
d-i-s-c-r-e-e-t which is how you're
supposed to spell that uh there were
also some more obvious ones like he used
Creek like a running creek like
c-r-e-e-k when he met Creek like a wood
like a you know floorboard creaking
c-r-e-a-k
there was also one point where he used
pedaled
p-e-d-d-l-e-d which means like selling
something instead of peddled a bicycle
like p d p e d a l e d
um one time two he used brakes like
something breaks instead of car breaks
uh you know b-r-e-a-k-s instead of
b-r-a-k-e-s and there was one instance
too where he wanted to say no nothing
like somebody that knows nothing k-n-o-w
but he used know nothing like no nothing
which I thought was like really odd now
these were just the ones that I caught
so this definitely needed like another
pass-through with an editor like I
realized I'm very very anal retentive
but that homophone thing it really like
I mean and that like I said there might
have been more than that but those were
just the ones that like immediately
stood out to me so yeah this really
definitely needed another pass through
an editor like I understand that like a
spell check isn't going to catch that
because the words aren't spelled
incorrectly you're just using them
incorrectly you're using like a
homophone you know what I mean and
that's something that I see turn up a
lot in books which is crazy there was
also a thing where the story had this
really weird habit of like introducing
like a minor character like the janitor
at the high school for example or like
the stoner guy who worked at the video
store and then giving them this sort of
like elaborate backstory for a few
paragraphs before they got horribly
killed like by the monster like I get
that a horror story of this type like
needs monster fodder obviously and to be
fair a lot of slasher movies try to do
this kind of thing like where they
introduce and try to humanize a
character like just moments before they
ultimately get bumped off in horrible
ways but it still comes across as like a
little bit forced to kind of be
introduced to the town drunk and read
his like pitiful you know tale of Woe
that went on uh before just like just
before he gets taken out like I did like
that
a lot of the message of the Behind These
vignettes was that you know oh you can't
judge people like oh you think the guy
that's on the video store is just like
this Stoner guy or you think the town
drunk is just like this bomb or whatever
so it's nice to have like some backstory
of like oh that's how he ended up in
that situation and he actually like is a
good guy but like bad circumstances so I
like that that was kind of like the the
running theme of those vignettes but I
do kind of wish that the characters had
been introduced earlier and like
Incorporated more into the overarching
plot like before they got killed so you
would actually have more time to get to
know them rather than like hey I showed
up here's my backstory and Bam and then
they were dead you know what I mean I
just thought that was like a little bit
yeah they just needed to be like
Incorporated a little bit more like in
the beginning so you know on the whole
uh this book had some problems but I
think the story idea was like a solid uh
story idea and I think kind of like
maybe with more experience more polish
stuff like that because like I said it's
a very new author
um I think that he will actually like
produce some great story stories down
the line so you know I'll be on the
lookout for whatever he does next and
that'll do it for this tomes of Terror I
hope to see you guys on the next one bye